مساء الخير واهلا بكم الى هذه الساعه
الاخباريه المستمره للاحداث في السودان في
يومها الثالث عشر اخر التطورات تمثلت في
هدنه هشه دخلت يومها الثالث والاخير وسط
مساع لتمديدها لاثنتين وسبعين ساعه ياتي
هذا الاعلان من نقابه اطباء السودان
بارتفاع عدد القتلى المدنيين جراء
الاشتباكات الى 3 اشخاص اضافه لتسجيل اكثر
من 1800 حاله اصابه بين المدنيين منذ
بدايه الاشتباكات
[موسيقى]
في ظل هذه الاشتباكات بين المكونين
العسكريين في السودان اكدت نقابه اطباء
السودان ثلاثه اطفال لقوا حتفهم في مدينه
الاوبيض في شمال كردفان وذلك نتيجه انفجار
قديفه وقالت ان عدد القتلى ارتفع الى 303
اشخاص اذ استمرار تبادل اطلاق النار
المستمر وفي حين سجلت النقابه اصابات بلغت
1848 حاله بين المدنيين منذ بدايه الصراع
موضحه ان العديد من الاصابات والوفيات غير
مشموله في هذه الاحصائيه لعدم تمكنها من
الوصول للمستشفيات بسبب صعوبه التنقل
والوضع الامني في البلاد
افاد مراسل العربيه بان طيران الجيش
النغارات على مواقع الدعم السريع في محيط
القياده العامه وفي ظل استمرار الاشتباكات
بين المكونين العسكريين في السودان اكدت
نقابه اطباء السودان ان ثلاثه اطفال لقوا
حتفهم في مدينه الابيض في شمال كردفان
نتيجه انفجار قذيفه وقالت ان عدد القتلى
تسعى الى 3 اشخاص اثر استمرار تبادل اطلاق
النار المستمر في حين سجلت النقابه اصابات
بلغت 1848 حاله بين المدنيين منذ بدايه
الصراع موضحه ان العديد من الاصابات
والوفيات غير مشموله في هذه الاحصائيه
لعدم تمكنها من الوصول الى المستشفيات
بسبب صعوبه التنقل والوضع الامني في
البلاد
واتهمت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش بشن هجوم
ضد قواتها في معسكر في منطقه كافوري في
الخرطوم بحري بالطيران والمدفعيه وقالت في
بيانها انه تم التصدي للهجوم والسيطره على
عتاد عسكري وقالت ايضا ان الجيش يواصل شن
هجمات على معسكراته رغم الهدنه الانسانيه
افاد مراسل العربيه بوقوع اشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع خلال
الساعات الاخيره في غرب وجنوب مدينه ام
درمان بولايه الخرطوم واوضحها ان اشتباكات
عنيفه شهدتها المنطقه القريبه من سوق
ليبيا غرب المدينه وان الجيش السوداني دفع
بتعزيزات عسكريه عبر شارع النيل باتجاه
جسر شنبات اما مدينه خلخرطوم بحري فشهدت
اشتباكات بين الطرفين وان كانت بوتيره اقل
حده من الاشتباكات في ام درمان
اظهرت صور خاصه للعربيه الخلو التام لشارع
النيل في ام درمان صباح اليوم من السيارات
والماره
[موسيقى]
ننتقل الى بورد سودان ومراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي نزار ما الجديد لديك في المشهد
والصراع على الارض
نحن وصلنا الان قبل قليل في هذا النقل
المباشر والحصري لقناه العربيه نحن الان
نتحدث من داخل العباره القطع البحريه
التابعه للبحريه الملكيه السعوديه جلاله
الملك البيل التي وصلناها الان هي في عرض
البحر بعد ان تم نقل كل البعثات
الدبلوماسيه في هذه المرحله مرحله الاجلاء
الان الاطقم المعنيه بهذه الباخره تقوم
بترتيبات المتعلقه بنقل البعثات
الدبلوماسيه الى داخل هذه القطعه البحريه
التابعه للملكيه البحريه السعوديه التي
هيات على ما يبدو كافه الاجواء وهيات كافه
السبل لراحه البعثات الدبلوماسيه الحديث
عن اثنين وخمسين من الشخصيات الدبلوماسيه
الان وصلوا الى هذه القطعه البحريه جلاله
الملك دبيل التي هيات كما نتابع
ممثلين البعثات الدبلوماسيه ورعاي الدول
الاجنبيه الذين وصلوا الى مدينه بورسودان
بشرق السودان على مدى ثلاثه ايام في رحله
تستمر في معاناه ولكنهم وصلوا بسلام الان
كما تتابعون في هذه الصور المباشره من
داخل جلاله الملك جبيل هذه القطع البحريه
السعوديه التابعه للبحريه الملكيه
السعوديه
الاسر الان تشعر بالسعاده وتشعر بالامتنان
لكل المساعي وكل ما بذر من جهود سواء كان
من الجيش السوداني او من السفاره السعوديه
في الخرطوم او من البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه التي تواصل الان اجلاء الرعايه
واجلاء المبعوثين في هذه العمليه عمليه
النقل من القدعه البحريه التي تعرض
بالطاقه هنا في ميناء بورسودان هي قطعه
بحريه صغيره
ركب فيها الرعايه وممثلي البعثات انتقلوا
في رحله استمرت لنحو اربعين دقيقه من مرسى
مينا بورسودان الى هذه المنطقه هنا في
البحر وبعدها مباشره سينتقلون بعد نصف
ساعه من الان تحديدا في رحله ستستمر الى
ثمانيه ساعات من بورسودان الى مدينه جده
الان الاطقم العسكريه والفنيه التابعه
لهذه الباخره تواصل مساعده
المبعوثي الدول ورعايه الدول الاجنبيه في
الصعود الى الباخره القطعه العسكريه
التابعه للملكيه البحريه
السعوديه في رحله نحاول ان نستطلع
الكثيرين منهم عبر هذه الرحله التي بدات
من بورسودان واستمرت الى ان وصلت الى هذه
المنطقه هنا في هذه الباخره في رحله تستمر
وفي اجلاء يستمر بدا منذ الحادي والعشرين
من هذا الشهر وما زال مستمرا حتى الان
اجراءات
متواصله وعمليات كثيره
متواصله لكل الذين
سعوا ويمضون من اجل اتمام هذه العمليه
التي وصفت بانها معقده في بداياتها ولكن
الان تمضي بسلام وبيسر وصولا الى هذه
المرحله مرحله العبور الى الباخره الملكيه
التي ستعبر بعد قليل الى من جده الدولي
عشر ساعات سيقضيها كل من وصل الى هذه
الباخره من اجل الوصول الى ميناء جده
هذه الرحله
ستعشر ساعات يبدو ان هناك يعني تجهيزات
ومواد غذائيه مؤونه لهؤلاء الذين سينتقلون
من بورتسودان الى جده هل مازلت معي نزار
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال معك نزار
ولكن سننتقل الى ولايه ميرلينج الامريكيه
وينضم الينا من هناك الباحث السياسي دكتور
صلاح البشير اهلا بك معنا الدكتور يعني
بالامس شهدنا اتهامات من مسؤولين امريكيين
سابقين يعني مثل
البرتوفرنانديز وكان هناك دونالد بوت
كاميرنه هاتسن يتهمون الاداره الامريكيه
اداره بايدن تحديدا
باهمال الوضع في السودان والتعامل معها
بخفه سابقا وانا اتحدث عن عام 2021 عندما
اطاح الجنرالان
بحكومه المدنيه هل هذه الاتهامات للحكومه
الامريكيه واداره بايدن مشروعه هل بالفعل
تعاملت اداره بايدن بشكل مختلف مع الازمه
في السودان انذاك يمكن ان يكون المشهد
مختلف اليوم
مرحبا بكم مره ثانيه
وهذا صحيح نعم اداره بايدن لاسباب كثيره
تختص بهذه الاداره
كانت تؤجل النظر بجديه للملف السوداني
بشكل عام وما حدث للخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر
2020 كان
انذارا شديدا اللهجه للاداره الامريكيه
للدخول
وقراءه الملف السوداني بشكل مختلف لكن
تقعست هذه الاداره الاسباب داخليه ولاسباب
خاصه
بمشاكل الاقتصاد
وبعد ذلك الحرب الاوكرانيه وما الى ذلك كل
هذه الامور اجلت الملف السوداني الى حين
خاصه وان ذلك
لاعبين اخرين
يعني يدرسون الملف السوداء السوداني من
بوجهات نظر مختلفه ربما لا لا تتحدث هنا
عن روسيا والصين دكتور
روسيا والصين وحتى من ناحيه الاقليميه مصر
تنظر الى السودان بشكل مختلف عما تنظر
اليه الولاده المتحده الامريكيه
بشكل عام الامارات والسعوديه على راسه
ينظرني الى السودان بشكل مختلف تماما عن
الملف الامريكي ولهذا لا توجد وحده
اقليميه دوليه سواء ان السودان لديه
اشكاليه ويجب النظر اليها لكن
الاجنده لكل وجهات نظر تختلف اختلافا
كبيرا وهذا يدلل على ان ما قام به
الامريكيون الان في محاوله الدفع
[موسيقى]
حكومه الامريكيه لاعاده النظر في الملف
السوداني بشكل يستحق خاصه ان السودان
محاط بسبع دول
هذه السبعه دول
تختلف في وجهه نظرها من حيث صيغه الحكم
عما يريده السوداني لذلك كان يجب
ان يدركوا ان النظر الى السودان يجب ان
يكون به
اضاف بان الولايات المتحده لم تهتم للشان
السوداني او حتى تهتم بافريقيا الا بعدما
اظهرت روسيا والصين اهتمام بهما اذا
الموضوع برايه هو مجرد منافسه
لا نستطيع ان
نضع المنافسه جانبا لان
يعني هاتين القوتين او الثلاثه تعتبر قوه
عظمى تبحث عن عن مصالحها وعن الموارد في
اماكن اخرى وافريقيا بشكل عام
وخاصه السودان
يملك يملك الكثير من
الموارد الطبيعيه التي لا يمكن
ان تترك لجهه واحده او لجهتين
قريبان في وجهه نظريهما من بعده البعض
وتبتعد الولايات المتحده عن ذلك خاصه وان
السودان يعتبر معبر يعني السودان بوابتين
ليس بوابه واحده بوابه باتجاه الشرق
الاوسط وبوابه باتجاه القرن الافريقي
وبوابه ثالثه
صف سحاره يعني تحت الصحراء فلذلك هنالك
مشكله في وجهه النظر الامريكيه ويجب ان
تدفع
بشكل افضل للدراسه الامر وان يوضع السودان
موضع الاهتمام الذي يستغل طيب برايك يا
دكتور
الطريقه الانسب للاداره الامريكيه للتعامل
مع الملف السوداني الان
اولا تحقيق رغبه السودانيين في الانتقال
الى السلطه المدنيه بدون هذا الامر سيظل
السودان رواحا بين حرب وحرب
لذلك اذا لم تحقق هذه الرغبه لن يجدي
الامر في الامر الثاني والمهم جدا جدا هو
تطوير
الادوات
السياسيه والعسكريه بحيث ان
يدرك كل طرف من الطرفين من الاطراف ومهمه
الاساسيه الامر الاخر هو الدفع بالاستثمار
باتجاه السودان وهذا لن يتاتى الا اذا كان
هنالك جهه
[موسيقى]
مدنيه هي التي تحكم ان هنالك ديمقراطيه
وان كل وسائل وادوات الحكم الديمقراطي تم
التعامل معاها
اذا يبقى الحل في وجود حكومه مدنيه بعيده
عن الكيانات العسكريه ابقى معنا دكتور
كرمال لنعود اليك لاحقا ولحديثنا بقيه
نشد مواطن سوداني قبيل مغادرته الى الحدود
المصريه ناشد رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
وقائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان ونشد قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدانو المعروف
بحميتي ناشدهما بوقف الحرب اكراما للشعب
وان يعودا الى طاوله الحوار
السيد البرهان وسيد حميد يوقف الحرب يا
جماعه نسبه لتعب الشعبي وللمعاناه التي
عاناها الشعب السوداني الذي لم يستحق هذه
المعاناه يا جماعه ارجوكم رد خاص في طاوله
بتاعه حوار وكل خلافات كل لان خلافاتكم
شخصيه جماعه
يا جماعه ربنا ده سبحانه وتعالى هيحاسبكم
على ما فعلتوه في الدنيا وفي الاخره
يصل الى مصر الاف من السودانيين كل يوم
عبر طرق البريه هربا من الاحداث في بلادهم
ملايين السودانيين يعيشون في مصر ومن
النازحين من يستقر في اسوان اقرب المدن
المصريه للحدود وللثقافه السودانيه ومنهم
من يتوجهوا الى مدن اخرى وخاصه القاهره في
كنف الاقارب او المعارف مراسل العربيه
التقى احدى العائلات الفاره من السودان
ونقل قصتها من سياق او في سياق هذا
التقرير
ان تعود الى منزلك مطمئنا انك ستجد اسرتك
في امان هذا يساوي الكثير عند عبد اللطيف
حامد المقيم في مصر منذ سنوات بعد ان كاد
القلق يفتك به خوفا على اسرته التي كانت
تحاول الهروب من الاشتباكات الدائره في
السودان ووصلت بسلام الى مصر منذ ثلاثه
ايام انا كنت جالك جدا وكنت متابعا
بالتليفون عبر التلفونات وعبر الواتساب
لحظه انه الاتصال اتقطع بيني وبينه بكون
دايما خايف وعايش في رعب شديد انه البلد
ما امنه يعني حتى لحد الحمد لله لحد ما
وصلوا اسطوان وكنت متابعين خطوه بخطوه
وكلمه بكلمه قرار الخروج من كسلا ومن
السودان صوب مصر اتخذته السيده سوسن
وابنتها ريما خوفا على اولادهما قبل الحرب
كانت صعبه
وهسه زاد الوضع سوق عندنا العيش في
المخابز ما في الغاز ما في كهرباء ما في
مويه ما في يعني الحياه انعدمت تماما يعني
في اي لحظه نحن ممكن نضيع اولاده مني اما
الرحله الطويله التي استغرقت ثلاثه ايام
فكانت خليطا من المشقه والخوف في الطريق
عايزين ياكلوا عايزين يشربوا عايزين
يناموا مرتاحين فهمته وبعدين صوت النار
العلاج بيخافوا في الايام العاديه غير
الحرب كان في نهر
يعني انت بتيجي ماشي بالعربيه فين في في
ناس بيموت وكده في الطريق يعني هسه احنا
لما جاي قلبنا في يدنا في المرعب
يعني
في الشوارع ويجر رصاص والباباني بتوعه
والحريق لا نحن محتاجين دكتور نفساني
والله العظيم يعني يعني انا ما اعرف انا
ما قريت الملف لكن الوضع
يعني مستحيل انك تشوف يعني انت في لحظه
وانت قاعد في بيتك مطمئن فجاه تلقى نفسك
اخيرا تم لم شمل الاسره بعد عناء تركوه
وراء ظهورهم مع ما تركوه من امتعه في
بيتهم المغلق في كسلا فهم جاءوا باقل
القليل من الملابس ويشعرون بعدم الثقه في
ان محنتهم ستنتهي قريبا تامر نصرت العربيه
القاهره
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحفي النور احمد
النور اهلا بك معنا بدايه لنتحدث عن هذا
اليوم الاخير من الهدنه والساعات الاخيره
في يومها الثالث كيف هي مجريات المعارك
والاشتباكات المستمره رغم الهدنه
نعم منذ بدات هذه الهدنه قبل يومين لم
تتوقف المعارف واجهات ولكنها كانت
اقل حته قبل وتركزت في المناطق البعيده من
مراكز المدن في شرق النيل وفي الخرطوم ام
درمان اليوم
في منطقه حله كوكو في بحري في منطقه السوق
المحلي في جنوب الخرطوم بدات الاسواق
تنتائج وافاق المواطنون من الصدمه كانت
هناك صدمه اعتقد انه
مع هذه الاوضاع
وبدات الحياه تدب قليلا في بعض المناطق
ولكن المعالج الانسانيه لا تزال مستمره في
كثير من احياء الخرطوم المياه الكهرباء
المستشفيات كثيره معطل ايضا هناك مشكله
اخرى اقتصاديه حيث ان المصارف والبنوك لم
تفتح ابواب
ومن ولا توجد سيوله نقديه لدى المواطنين
وبعض التطبيقات البنكيه لا تعمل وبالتالي
المواطن حتى لو هناك متاجر فاتحه لا
يستطيع شراء لانه
نقديه ولا يستطيع ان يشتري حاجات هذه
مشكله اعتقد انها تواجه الكثير من
المواطنين في الخرطوم ايضا الذين ينمون
مغادره الخرطوم الى الولايات
التذاكر البطاقات السفر تم تضاعفت اكثر من
خمس مرات حتى الذين يريدون المغادره الى
مصر واثيوبيا مثلا ايضا تذاكر السفر صارت
مغدر كثير من المواطنين هذه ايضا مشتري
يعاني منها المواطنون حتى الذين يرغبون
ليس لديهم سيوله الكافيه وليس لديهم اموال
الكافيه يظل المغالاه من الاطراف التي
تستغل هذه الاوضاع لمضاعفه الاسعار بصوره
جنونيه طيب ماذا عن الوضع الصحي عن
المستشفيات عن المصابين الذين كان هناك
صعوبه في انتقالهم من بيوتهم او اماكن
تضررهم الى المستشفيات كانت المستشفيات
مكتظه كذلك صحيح النور
نعم المستشفيات التي تعمل مقتصد جدا
والمستشفيات المرجعيه الكبيره هي تقع في
موقع الاشتباكات في وسط الخرطوم المراكز
الصحيه في الاحياء لا تعمل بصوره كافيه
وتعتقد هذه هي المخرج ينبغي لوزاره الصحه
ان تركز على المراكز الصحيه المنتشره في
داخل الاحياء التي يسهل للمواطن الوصول
اليها ويمكن
كوادر متطوعه من من الاطباء والكوادر
الصحيه الموجودين في داخل الدين لا
يستطيعون الوصول الى المستشفىات يمكن ان
يعملوا في هذه المراكز يمكن التحدي انه
وزاره الصحه ينبغي ان توفر الملتز
المستلزمات الطبيه
تستطيع هذه المراكز ان تمتص كثير من
الجرحى والذين لا يحتاجون مثلا الى عمليات
معقده يحتاجون الى جروحه او امراض عاديه
بالتالي يمكن لهذه المراكز انها في حال
استطاعت وزاره الصحه ان تشغل هذه المراكز
عبر الكوادر الصحيه والمنظمات التطوعيه
والمتطوعين من ابناء هذه الاحياء النور
لنتحدث قليلا عن مبادره ايجاد التي يبدو
ان البرهان قد وافق عليها هل من رده فعل
من الدعم السريع حول هذه المبادره حتى
اللحظه
نعم البرهان وافق عليها مبدئيا بالطبع
البرهان نفسه هو رئيس الان رئيس الد
ور الهيئه الحكوميه للتنميه في شقه
افريقيا ايجاد اعتقد ان هذا هو سبب عدم رد
الدعم السريع يبدو ان الدعم السريع لا زال
يفكر
منذ اعلان موافقته لم يرد الدعم السريع
رسميا على هذه المبادره يبدو انه لا يزال
يدرسها
واعتقد انه يمكن ان يكون لديه تحفظات لذلك
انه يريد باعتبار ان البرهان هو يراس هذه
الهيئه وبالطبع هيئه حكوميه ولكن لدينا
نفوز استطاعت هذه الهيئه
كانت هي التي ترعى اتفاق السلام بين زمانه
والجنوب السودان قبل الانفصال 2005 وايضا
راحت الاتفاق في جنوب السودان بين الرئيس
الفقير
ايضا لديها ادوار كبيره في السودان وهي
جزء من الاليه الثلاثيه التي تضم الامم
المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي التي الان ترعى
عمليه السلام في السودان وبالتالي هي
مؤهله ان تلعب هذا الدور وان كان ليس
لديها يعني
طرفين ولكن اعتقد ان مرافقه البرهان حتى
لقطع الطريق عموميه بالطبع جلس
العمليه عمليه الهدنه وعمليه السلام في
السودان الى المنظمات اللبنانيه اللي هي
قادره الاتحاد الافريقي المعنيه بهذه
القضيه ولكن
الموافقه البرهان اعتقد لقطع الطريق امام
اي تدخلات عموميه
بالتالي عندما تتولى المنظمه الاقليميه
هذا الامر هذا سيمنع اي تدخل من الامم
المتحده اخرى
اعتقد ان
المحفوظات
القوات الدعم السريع التي
طيب هل هناك مخاوف في الداخل السودانيه
النور من تصاعد وتيرات الاشتباكات بعد
انتهاء هذه الهدنه ام هناك امال بتمديدها
بالفعل اثنتين وسبعين ساعه اخرى
انا ارجع ان تمدد هذه الهدنه 72 رغم ان
عدم التزام الطرفين بهذه الهدوم بدايتها
ولكنها اشعه جو من الامل انه يمكن ان
تتمدد هذه الهده وتتحول الى دائم لاطلاق
النار اذا تم تمديد الهدنه اليوم وهذا
يعطي فرصه امل جديده
ويسمح للمنظمات الطوعيه والانسانيه ان
توصل المساعدات الى المحتاجين في كثير من
الاحياء الخرطوم ايضا توفر مناخ افضل
للحوار بين الطرفين انه مبادره ايجاد
اقترحت ان يذهب منذوبان يمثل القوات
القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع الى جبهه
للتفاوض في هذا الامر هذا
افضل اذا استمرت الهدنه المواطنون الان في
هذه الهجره الاشتباكات المستمره
الاحياء اسواق وحركه المرور تزايدت على
الطرقات واذا استمرت هذه الهدنه هذا افضل
للمواطن
لاتخاذ انفاسه والتعامل بطريقه ايجابيه
لتحسين اوضاعه المعي
شه طيب النور ابقى معي كرما لانتقل سريعا
الى مراسلنا في جده هاني الصفيان ويبدو ان
هناك دفعه جديده من الرعايه الذين تم
اجلائهم من السودان الى جده هاني اليك
نعم اهلا بك فاطمه واهلا مجددا على شاشه
العربيه العربيه ما زالت تواكب اصول رعايه
من دول عده قادمين من السودان قبل قليل
كنا نرصد ثلاث سفن عسكريه سفينتين صينيتين
عسكريتين وصلتا الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
وتحمل قرابه
670 من رعايا الصين وكذلك السفينه الثالثه
هي سفينه هنديه وتحمل قرابه المئتين وخمسه
وتسعين شخص هؤلاء الدفعه الاخيره من رعايه
الصين هم يقومون بانهاء اجراءاتهم عبر
المنصات الخاصه والكونترات الخاصه في صاله
القدوم في ميناء جده الاسلامي هنا في
المنطقه الخاصه بالجوازات السعوديه للحديث
اكثر ينضم معي الرائد حامد الحارثي وهو
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الجوازات
السعوديه هنا في المنطقه الغربيه مرحبا بك
رائد
دعنا نتحدث اولا يعني الوضع الذي يحدث
الان هي وضع كحاله طارئه
لابد ان يكون هناك خطه طوارئ لديكم لو
نتحدث عنها في البدايه انا بدايه ارحب فيك
وفي الساده المشاهدين امتدادا للجهود
المبذوله التي تقدمها حكومه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لاجلاء المواطنين ورعايا
الدول المديريه العامه للجوازات سخرت كافه
الامكانات
لاستقبال هؤلاء المواطنين والرعايه وانهاء
وانهاء اجراءات دخولهم في وقت قياسي وكذلك
بسهوله
هنالك متابعه واشراف على مدار 24 ساعه من
قبل القيادات القطاع وذلك للاطلاع على سير
العمل ومعالجه ما يتطلب معالجته بشكل فوري
وذلك تعزيزا للدور الذي تقوم به المملكه
العربيه السعوديه طيب يعني خلال الثلاث
ايام الماضيه الكاميرا العربيه كانت ترصد
تزايد في اعداد الرعايه اليوم امس كان 400
اليوم الف شخص من رعايه الصين والهند يوم
امس بعثه الامم المتحده ايضا هناك عمليات
اجلاء لمواطنين قرابه
2500 كيف تقومون بتسخير الجهود هنا او
الاعداد بالنسبه
لضباط الصف والمنصات الخاصه بنهاء الجوز
انهاء الاجراءات القدوم المديريه العامه
للجوازات الممثله في جوازات منطقه مكه
المكرمه تستقبل المواطنين ورعايه الدول عن
طريق ميناء جده الاسلامي وكذلك مطار الملك
عبد العزيز الدولي تم دعم هذه
المنطقه بالاعداد اللازمه بالتقنيه
الحديثه وذلك لانهاء الاجراءات ايضا
يتم معالجه اوضاع القادمين الذين لا
يحملون تاشيرات ولا يحملون جوازات سفر نعم
وذلك
لا يحملون جوازات وتاشيرات ماذا ما هو
الحال به نعم
تتم
تتم معالجه اوضاعهم
بمنحهم تاشيرات نعم
خلينا يعني نقوم بعمليه انت تذكرت فكره
التقنيات ونشاهد فعلا اخذ العلامات
الحيويه وكذلك انها الاجراءات دعنا نتحدث
عن المده يعني نتكلم اليوم عن الف هل
ينتظرون ساعات طوال المده التي يتم انهاء
فيها هذه الاجراءات نعم يتم اخذ الخصائص
الحيويه وانهاء اجراءات دخول القادمين في
مده لا تتجاوز العشرين ثانيه عشرين ثانيه
لكل شخص يعني تكون العمليه اسهل واسرع
صحيح شكرا لك الرائد حمد اذا كان هذا حديث
الرائد حمد الحارثي او المتحدث باسم
الجوازات السعوديه هنا في المنطقه الغربيه
وهذه احدى السيدات التي قدمت من الصين اول
لقتي قدمت من السودان الرائعه الصين
بانهاء خصائصها لحيويه وكذلك ايضا اخذ
المعلومات الاخيره والتاكد من المعلومات
الاخيره من موظف الجوازات هناك ايضا كما
تحدث حمد الحارثي ان الذين اشخاص الذين
ليس لديهم تاشيراتهم نحلهم تاشيرات سريعه
حتى يتم مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم هنا تتضح
ايضا عمليه شرح موظف الجوازات الذين
يتحدثون بعده لغات
يقوم بشرح لاحد الرعايه الصين في وضع
اصابعه تظهر هذه العلامات الحيويه كما
نشاهدها الان هذه تجربه حيه ترصدها كاميرا
العربيه
لوضع
توضيح واظهار العلامات الحيويه من خلال
البصمه واظهار صورته او اخذ لقطه لصورته
وكذلك بياناته فهناك بعض الاشخاص الذين
ليس لهم تاشيرات ولكن تمنح لهم تاشيرات
عاجله وسريعه حتى يتم مغادرتهم الى
بلدانهم بسلام شكرا لك من جده مراسله
العربيه هاني الصفيان وشكر جزيل لضيفك
الكريم
قبل ذلك وصلت الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده وصلت السفينه العسكريه
السعوديه الثامنه والتي تحمل على متنها
180 شخصا من جنسيات متعدده بعد اجلائهم من
بورتسودان التفاصيل معها نصفيان
ما مجددا العربيه مستمره في مواكبه وصول
السفن العسكريه وكذلك السفن التجاريه التي
تصل الى مدينه جده هنا هذه هي السفينه
السعوديه العسكريه الثامنه التي تصل في
هذه اللحظات وهي جلاله الملك الطائف وعلى
متنها اكثر من 180
شخص يحملون عده جنسيات طبعا للتو هذه
السفينه وصلت هذه اللحظه في قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في مدينه جده غرب السعوديه
تحدث اليوم عن اكثر من 96 جنسيه قامت
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه باجلاعهم
من السودان الى مدينه جده هناك ايضا
فرقاطات
عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي ونتحدث عن فرقاطات
ايضا عسكريه قبل هذه السفينه وصلت سفينتين
حربيتين صينيتين وتحملان على متنهما اكثر
من 700 شخص من المواطني الصين وكذلك قبلها
في ساعات الصباح الاولى وصلت سفينه عسكريه
هنديه كانت تحمل قرابه
300 شخص من رعايه الهند وكل جميعهم وصلوا
الى مدينه جده
استعدادا
لعمليه مغادرتهم عبر مطار الملك عبد
العزيز الدولي في مدينه جده
وفيما يتواصل اعلان الهدن في السودان
تتواصلوا عمليات الاجلاء لرعايه الدول من
البلاد لكن هذه العمليه تواجه تحديات
كثيره خصوصا على السودانيين الراغبين في
الهرب من ساحات المواجهات الى مناطق ابعد
او حتى الى خارج البلاد
تشتد الازمه هناك وتنفرج في المعابر
والموانئ والمطارات لكن قبل الوصول الى بر
الامان ثم تحديات يجب تخطيها
ولعل الوضع الامني المتردي اخطر تحدي لذا
تشكل الهدن متنفسا للحركه لكن ذلك مرهون
بالتزام طرفي النزاع بوقف اطلاق النار
فمنذ اكثر من عشره ايام اعلن عن اربع هدى
بواسطات دوليه العنوان الابرز لها خروق
وانهيار العائق الثاني في حال تجاوز
الفرينه هشاشه الهدن يتمثل في كلفه التنقل
فثمن تذكره الرحله الى بورتسودان من
الخرطوم في الحافله يصل الى اربع مئه
دولار للشخص الواحد لكن ثمه ازمه اخرى
محطات وقود مغلقه اما الانقطاع الوقود او
الاستهدافها تشهد الاسعار ارتفاعات كبيره
فتكلفه الجالون في السوق السوداء بلغت 50
دولارا اي عشره اضعاف السعر الرسمي
وللتنقل لابد من الدفع هنا مشكله اخرى لا
محلات صيرفه ولا صرافات اليه والبنوك
مغلقه حتى تحويل الاموال عبر تطبيقات
الهواتف لا يعمل معضله اخرى قذائف وشظايا
لم تنفجر قد تكون في انتظار اصطياد ضحيتها
لذا تشدد المنظمه على تجنب التعامل مع اي
منها
[موسيقى]
في ظل هذه الخيارات المره والصعبه يختار
البعض المخاطره غير ان اخرين يفضلون
البقاء في منازل ستكون بالنسبه لهم اكثر
امنا من مخاطر رحله قد لا تكون محسوبه
العواقب
اعتقد السبب الرئيسي لهذا الامر
وان
مجلس العقد والربطي صح هذا التعبير في
الدعم السريع لا يستطيع ان يلتقي لان
الضربات المتلاحقه
شتت
هذه المجموعه واصبح الاتصالات ما بينها
وبين بعضها البعض صعب جدا
الامر الاخر هو ما ذكره
مراسلكم بان وجود البرهان على راس هذه
الدوره
يعني يحدث كثيرا من الهم والغم بالنسبه
لهذه المجموعه خاصه وان هنالك
كثير من الوجده الشخصي بين الرجلين لذلك
ربما يكون ايضا هذا عاملا مؤثرا في
يتاخر على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه
الرد الحاسم بخصوص هذه المبادره طيب في
حديثنا قبل قليل دكتور يعني ذكرت بان من
الحلول المطروحه او للوضع في السودان من
الجانب الامريكي بان يكون هناك تطوير
للادوات السياسيه والعسكريه واضفت الى ذلك
بانه يجب الدفع بالاستثمار تجاه السودان
يعني سؤالي هو في خصوص الاستثمار في
السودان يعني كيف يمكن لاي مستثمر ان يرغب
في ذلك في الوضع الراهن يعني ما الخطوه
الذي التي يجب ان يتخذونها قبل ان يباشروا
ويبادروا بالاستثمار في الداخل السوداني
وانا اتحدث عن الاداره الامري كيه
اذا ارادت الاداره الامريكيه
حلا
ناجعا للاستثمار في السودان فيجب ان تكون
هي من الاساس لهذا الاست
الوضع في السودان وضع لا يشحذمم
المستثمرين للدخول فيه الا اذا كانوا
يريدون ان يستثمروا بمخاطر عاليه جدا وهذا
ليس ديدا رؤوس الاموال في اي مكان في
الدنيا
يريدون قدرا محددا او قدرا معينا من
الامان الذي يسمح لهم بالتحرك والذي يسمح
لهم باختيار نوعيه استثماراتهم وايضا يسمح
لهم
بالانتاج لذلك فان الضامن الوحيد في هذا
الامر هو
الولايات المتحده اذا ارادت الولايات
المتحده ان تفعل ذلك ايضا يمكن ان يشارك
الولايات المتحده في ذلك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ودوله الامارات العربيه
يمكنهما ان يشارك الولايات المتحده في ذلك
طيب شكرا دكتور ابقى معي قليلا لاعود اليك
بعد قليل
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن تنفيذها
عمليات اجلاء جديده في السودان مؤكده ان
عمليات الاجلاء شملت مواطنينا فرنسيين
وكذلك مواطنين من بريطانيا الولايات
المتحده كندا واثيوبيا بالاضافه الى
هولندا ايطاليا والسويد كما اكدت انها
قامت حتى الان باجلاء اكثر من 930 شخص
حتى وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس كليفر
الرعايه البريطانيين في السودان الى
الالتحاق بالرحلات الجويه من دون تاخير
مشيرا الى ان بريطانيا قد لا تكون قادره
على مواصله عمليه الاجلاء عندما ينتهي وقف
اطلاق النار وقال ان الوقت قد حان لتسريع
تلك الجهود مشيرا الى نجاح بريطانيا في
اجلاء اكثر من 530 شخصا جوا من السودان
حتى الان
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الصينيه ان الصين
ارسلت سفن قواتها البحريه الى السودان
لاجلاء رعاياها وذلك من اجل حمايه ارواحي
وممتلكات المواطنين الصينيين وذلك وفق
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الصينيه تان
كيفي افاد المسؤول الصيني بان الوضع
الامني في السودان يتدهور بشكل مستمر مع
سعيد والعده الى اجلاء مواطنيها عن طريق
البحر او الجوي او البر
وقد بحث وزير الخارجيه الامريكيين الوضع
في السودان مع رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي موسى فكي وقال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه ماثيومر قال ان بلينكن
بحث مع رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي بحث
التعاون من اجل وقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه
وانهاء القتال في السودان واتفق الوزير
بلانكن وفكي على ان ضغط قياده الاتحاد
الافريقي على القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقوات الدعم السريع لا يزال ضروريا لوقف
فوري للعمليات العسكريه وللسماح بوصول
المساعدات الانسانيه من دون عوائق
بدا النزاع العسكري امال ملايين المواطنين
بانتهاء عقود الحصار والفقر والاستبداد في
السودان حيث تسببت المعارك الدائره بين
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش بخسائر اقتصاديه
مباشره وفادحه تقدر بمليارات الدولارات
وخسائر اخرى غير مباشره قد يطول امدها حال
لم يتوصل الطرفان الى اتفاق قريب لوقف
اطلاق النار
ما ان اطلقت اول رصاصه في مطار الخرطوم
الدولي حتى خسر السودان خمسه في المئه من
اجمالي صادراته ووارداته مليارات دولار من
عائدات صادرات الذهب توقفت هي الاخرى مثل
ما توقفت الحركه التجاريه مع مصر ملايين
الدولارات تتبعثر مع كل قذيفه تفجر مبنى
او تنسف جسرا انها ضريبه الحرب التي
يدفعها المواطنون
المشكله بقى خطير علينا يا جماعه
[موسيقى]
ان لم تهدا المدافع ستدخل البلاد في فوضى
عارمه يحذر الخبراء من مجاعه تطال الجميع
وحتى ان توقفت الحرب لن يعود التمويل
الدولي بسهوله ولا ثقه المستثمرين ولن
يعود هؤلاء النازحون لدفع عجله التنميه
السودانيه طالما ان بلد ثروات بلا استقرار
سياسي
وفي متابعه لعمليه الاجلاء على الحدود
المصريه والسودانيه معنا من معبر ارقين
على الحدود المصريه السودانيه مراسل
العربيه احمد عثمان اهلا بك احمد ما
الجديد لديك تفضل
الجديد هو استمرار تدفق الذين نجحوا في
الوصول الى هذا البعبر من الجانب السوداني
يعني حتى الان هناك استمرار وتفاوت في
خروج الذين وصلوا الى هذا المعبر الحدودي
معبر ارشين اغلب من يخرجون الان مع اليوم
الخامس عشر
او الرابع عشر لاندلاع الحروب هم من
السودانيين الذين فروا يعني هناك بالتاكيد
نسب من المصريين الذين جاؤوا تقلصت نسب
الاجانب الذين جاءوا خلال الايام الماضيه
اغلب من يخرجون الان هم من السودانيين
الوضع على نفس الوتيره هناك من يخرجون
ليتوجهون الى الحافلات هنا من حولي للتوجه
اما الى اسوان اغلبهم يتوجهون الى اسوان
او الى القاهره يعني يبقى بان الاغلب ما
كنا نسمعه
اثناء الحديث
نعم شكرا هذه هي مجموعه الحافلات التي
تبقى
منتظره امام بوابه المعبر في انتظار الذين
يخرجون منه للتوجه الى مدينه اسوان يعني
ربما كما ذكرت لك ان يعني اغلب الذين يقول
معهم يؤكدون بان هناك تكدس في الجانب
الاخر وايضا تكدس داخل المعبر بسبب يعني
الزحام الشديد يعني هناك الالاف الذين
يعني ينتظرون للدخول الى الجانب المصري
السلطات المصريه من جانبها تقوم بكافه
التسهيلات الممكنه ولكن هذا المعبر الذي
كان مخصص ربما لعبور المئات يوميا الان
بسبب الاحداث من المفترض انه يعبر منه
الالاف وهو ما يحتاج الى الكثير من الوقت
فيما يتعلق بالتوثيق بالتاكد من سلامه
الاوراق بالتاكد من التفتيش للسيارات ايضا
للتاكد من عدم وجود اي شبهه جنائيه او
امنيه لاي شخص قد يكون متسللا عائدا الى
مصر في اعقاب يعني من هربوا خلال العشره
الاعوام الماضيه بعد الاطاحه بحكم الاخوان
ولجوء كثير منهم الى السودان خلال هذه
السنوات الطويله وبالتالي هذا ربما
التاخير مبرر من قبل السلطات المصريه التي
تؤكد بانها تقدم جميع التسهيلات الممكنه
هناك يعني وجود للهلال الاحمر لسيارات
تابعه لوزاره الصحه المصريه لاطباء
لمتابعه كل من يخرج هذا فيما يتعلق بالوضع
داخل المعبر الوضع فيما يتعلق بخارج
المعبر فنحن نتحدث يعني لمده دقائق قليله
مع من يخرجون من المعبر والحديث يعني يبدو
متشابه حاله من الصدمه حاله من الغضب حاله
من القلق الكلام يبدو يعني كثير منه بانه
هناك تشابه يعني ماذا سيفعلون ما هي
الخطوات المقبله اغلبهم سيتوجهون الى مصر
بعضهم معهم يعني حقائب قليله اموال قليله
ما هو مستقبل المشهد السياسي والامن في
السودان كم سينكثون في مصر هل سيذهبون الى
اقارب او اصدقاء او الى فنادق كل هذه
الامور تبدو متشابهه على السن من نتحدث
اليهم جميعا كبارا كانوا ام صغارا شبابا
ام شيوخا نساء واطفال ربما الصدمه تبدو
اكبر على وجوه الاطفال الذين لم يستوعبوا
حتى الان هذه الرحله الخطيره هذه الايام
الخطيره التي عاشوها في السودان وهذه
الرحله الطويله والمرهقه للوصول الى
الحدود المصريه يعني سريعا يعني هناك
معضله تواجهها السلطات المصريه على الحدود
وهي هؤلاء من لم من لا يحملنا اي اثباتات
او هويات سريعا كيف يتم التعامل معهم
هناك يعني من يحمل اي اثباتات او اوهيات
او او تاشيرات يعني يتم الطلب منه خصوصا
اذا كان يعني في سن صغير هيتم الطلب منه
للعوده الى وادي حلفا وهي اقرب نقطه من
الحدود مع مصر لتوثيق الاوراق والتاكد من
الهويات واضح شكرا توثيق الاوراق والتاكد
مره اخرى للعود واضح شكرا لك ان الحدود
المصريه السودانيه مراسلنا احمد عثمان
وعبر عدد من طالبه الاجلاء للعربيه او
عبروا عن ارائهم ازاء الاجراءات والاوضاع
الراهنه
وصلنا بصعوبه صعوبه لا يعني ما توصف يعني
قاعد نمشي على القتلى وصلنا هنا لكن ما في
يعني عشره يوم مرت علينا يمكن اكلين عيشه
وحده الاف او عشان ما يكون في مبالغه مئات
من السوريين موجودين في الخرطوم ما قادرين
يتحركوا اولا انعدام الامان ثانيا الغلاء
الموجود في بالنسبه للترحيل ثالثا
زي ما قلنا الشوارع ما كلها امنه يعني
الحرمين الشريفين والمنكر العربيه
السعوديه الناس لكن نطلب رجاء خاص من
برهان مين حمدي الله يهديكم ربنا يهديكم
يعني شعب السوداني منتهي شعب سوداني في
شارع الجاليات في الشارع الناس يعني يعني
ما ممكن نفرين يتشاكلوا يضيعوا الناس في
النص
او طائرات الاجلاء التابعه لسلاح الجو
الاردني وعلامتها سبعون شخصا او سبعين
شخصا من المواطنين وجنسيات عربيه واجنبيه
من الهيئات الدبلوماسيه والمنظمات الدوليه
واكد الناطق باسم الخارجيه الاردنيه سنان
المجالي ان بلده سيستمر في تقديم يد العون
للدول الصديقه وللرعايه الاردنيين في
السودان ممن لديهم الرغبه في الخروج من
الاراضي السودانيه
يعني رحله كانت بر من الخرطوم لبورت سودان
عبر الامم المتحده اخذت تقريبا اربعين
ساعه بس الحمد لله انه يعني المملكه
الاردنيه يعني المبادره اللي عملوها
بشكروا عليها رحله من السودان من داخل
السودان صراحه كان في كثير مخاطر تعرضنا
لها لكن الحمد لله تيسرت والله كان الوضع
كتير صعب صعب كتير كتير يعني
فجاه صارت المشاكل وضرب يعني وانقطعت
الكهرباء والمي
وعلينا كتير
نعود الى الخرطوم وضيفي من هناك الصحفيه
نور احمد النور اهلا بك مجددا يعني عمليات
الاجلاء مستمره
السودانيون ايضا يحاولون الهرب من هذا
الوضع الماساوي في داخل السوداني بالتالي
سؤالي يعني هناك مخاوف من ان هؤلاء
السودانيون الذين يخرجون من السودان قد لا
يعودون اليها هل هذه المخاوف مشروعه النور
نعم بالطبع اي شخص خرج من السودان لجا او
ناجحا من الخرطوم لن يعود ما لم تتوقف
النار بصوره كامله وتطمئنان هناك حاله من
الامن والاستقرار لانه من دفعهم ما دفعوا
للخروج من بلادهم او مغادره الخرطوم هو
الحاله الانسانيه السيئه بالاضافه الى
اشتباكات العسكريه فلم تتوقف الحرب وتعود
الاوضاع تهدى الاوضاع الامن لا اعتقد انهم
سيعودون وهذا بطبع خساره لانه هؤلاء الان
حتى الان
ظهر عشرون الف الى تشاهد عبر الى مصر خلال
اربعه يوم عشره الاف
واربعه الف الى جنوب السودان هؤلاء نحو 40
الف الان خرجوا الامم المتحده وقع انف
يمكن ان يخرجوا من دول مجاوره خلال الايام
المقبله في حال لن تتوقف الحرب منها لهذه
خساره كبيره خساره كوادر بشريه او مواطنون
منتجون ولديهم اعمال تجاريه وبالتالي
نعمل ان تتوق
ف ممكنه حتى يعودوا لمباشره اعمالهم
والاتحاق بكسرهم الممتده في داخل السودان
شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم والصحفي النور
احمد النور
انتقل الى ولايه ميريلاند مجددا والباحث
السياسي دكتور صلاح البشير اهلا بك مجددا
دكتور اذا مبادره ايجاد تتضمن تمديد
للهدنه اثنتين وسبعين ساعه اخرى في ظل عدم
اي رده فعل من الدعم السريع حتى الان
هل هناك اي ردود فعل امريكيه او اي
تعليقات امريكيه في الصحف الاميركيه لديكم
حتى هذه اللحظه لم نطلع على
ما يفيد بان الاداره
الامريكيه غاضبه من عدم الرد على مبادره
الايجاز ولكن ربما يحدث ذلك في خلال ساعات
الاولى من هذا الصباح خاصه ونحن الان
لازلنا نحو الخامسه او السادس صباحا
فلا دال هنالك الكثير من الوقت حتى يستطيع
الناس هنا في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تنزلوا الى
العمل وان يدركوا ما يجب عليهم فعله خلال
هذا اليوم
لكن اتوقع ان ترد الاداره الامريكيه او
تدفع الاداره الامريكيه ولو خلصت الدعم
السريع الى الموافقه المبدئيه على
الايجاد على هذه المبادره حتى
ندفع بالعمليه السلبيه الى الامام ولو
بشكل مظهري او شكل اولي
حتى يضع كل طرف من الاطراف المتحاربه
قضيته امام الجميع
ويدركوا يدرك
المتحاورون ماذا يريد كل طرف من الاخر
واضح شكرا لك من ولايه مريلاند الامريكيه
الباحثه السياسي دكتور صلاح البشير
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات